welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Graham old an associate professor at
Carleton University in Canada in the
school of public policy and
administration professor Aldus here at
Yale University as a visiting associate
professor of Canadian Studies and
political science with broad interests
in comparative Environmental Policy and
global environmental governance his
research examines the emergence
evolution and impacts of non-state and
hybrid forms of global governance across
economic sectors particularly fisheries
agriculture and forestry he has
published widely on environmental
certification programs and environmental
policy and governance today we'll talk
with him about his forthcoming book
constructing private governance the rise
and evolution of forest coffee and
Fisheries certification welcome
professor all thank you very much it's
great to be here thank you what led you
to well let's start with an overview of
your book tell us about it okay so the
book is a long-standing project I've had
a long Stan it started the research side
about 2005 when i was here at yale doing
my PhD and the book is essentially an
effort to try and understand differences
in the way in which a form of private
governance a--'s has evolved and
developed in those three sectors so
coffee forestry and Fisheries and I was
particularly interested in some
differences that it emerged across those
three sectors having done a lot of work
on the forest sector before with a
faculty member here at Yale been cash or
we did a bunch of research on forestry
and as we are wrapping up one big
project on forestry we could really and
I got personally very interested in why
it looked like the patterns of the way
this particular form of governance was
evolving in coffee and Fisheries so the
book project is essentially an effort to
try and understand what is different
these sectors why particular patterns
have emerged across them okay and what
led you to write the book so I mean one
one reason is I just find a
certification quite fascinating that
essentially what it is is it's a system
where non-state actors sometimes
governments are involved more in a sort
of an advisory role but these non-state
actors like businesses NGOs other civil
society actors get together set
standards so in those standards focus on
environmental and social stewardship in
different sectors and then companies can
voluntarily adopt those standards get
certified against them and then have
their products carrying a label on an
end product so if this table was
certified if you bought it at Home Depot
you would see that it had a little label
on it that said this came from a
certified forest so the reason that's
interesting at least the reason
political scientists have thought that's
really interesting is that it seems to
be doing a lot of things that we
normally would think governments would
do so it's setting rules for social and
environmental outcomes that are often
thought of as things that governments
regulate and it's trying to manage
business activities make binding
decisions that actors have to follow so
I was really interested in where this
instrument came from and why was getting
traction in different sectors and the
forestry project was also interested in
that but this one took the next step to
think well what's why are we seeing such
different patterns when we look across
industrial sectors okay so in doing you
know so you're looking at fisheries
coffee and forced forestry how did you
do the research in terms of yes I mean
it seems very broad yeah very different
areas it's quite different so the the
book collects a lot of different types
of information the central interest was
in the program's themselves so you could
think about them as sort of private
bureaucracies so equivalent to a
government department that was running a
government program are there more than
one certification program per industry
says yes so the big patterns that I was
interested in is it in forestry the most
people understand it as a to program
competition so there's the Forest
Stewardship Council which is originally
backed by NGOs and some more on the
consumer end of the supply chain
companies like home depot or B&Q in
particular was a big supporter in the UK
and then an industry-backed program that
formed from landowners in europe that
weren't happy with the FSC so it was a
almost like to party competition
electoral system and in fisheries and
coffee the pattern was quite different
there were way more programs so i think
currently there might be five or six in
both of those sectors and so i was
really interested in why so much more
fragmentation in this private regulatory
field in the night of Fisheries in
comments what did you come up with why
is there and so the main the main
interest the book looked at was it's
there's a lot of work in political
science that looks at how small choices
in the past with scholars called path
dependencies may leave long legacies in
the way organizations or institutions
form and develop so I was interested in
were some very early choices these
programs made in some sectors having
legacy effects on the way they evolved
and also what kind of opportunities
there were four other programs to enter
those sectors to compete with those
initial programs so in that respect I
looked at a couple of key variables so
one was the character of the governance
process so how open they were two actors
even like yourself some programs would
allow almost anyone to become a member
and have an influence on the
decision-making processes and others are
much more closed and they only allow
very particular interest to have a role
so that was one variable that mattered
more openness less likely that you're
going to have more programs coming in
the other is the character of the
standards so the degree to which the
standards are really broad or narrow
affected how much competition came about
and whether they regulated all the
actors in the sector or a narrower
subset so a concrete example is fair
aid we yeah for coffee it's set up
initially in the Netherlands in the late
1980s and decided to focus only on
cooperatives so it only certifies fair
trade cooperatives and that meant that a
large portion of the global production
of coffee that comes from plantations
couldn't apply to the program because
they're not fair yeah so that was one of
the impetuses for another program to
enter the market to service that the
plantation coffee and then the final one
that I explores the role of market
demand and how market demand at that
early stage created more incentives to
enter or less incentives and internally
affected the interests of actors within
the programs to adapt or not to adapt
sir so why certify it's a great question
so that is one of the key challenges
these programs face and that's partly
why a lot of people are interested than
is that in the case of government when
government set rules governments can
sanction people if they don't adhere to
them so you can get fined if you don't
pay your taxes or if you really are bad
actor you can get thrown in jail and so
you can't do that with certification so
the main mechanism for sanctioning
essentially is demand in the marketplace
so consumerist you mean the end users or
do you mean something else yeah so
consumers play some role in some of the
programs so for instance I would imagine
some people would like with fair trade
coffee for instance some people would I
only drink fair trade coffee nothing
else in fact something like that yeah so
there's some of the labels that are much
more well known by end consumers so
organics are more well-known fair trade
it has a quite a large consumer yea high
levels of consumer awareness and but
even when people are aware there is
often slippage between what they say
they will do and what they actually do
so this is what behavioral economist or
economist in general talk about the
difference between willingness to pay
when you ask someone will you pay a
premium for this
mentally or socially friendly product a
lot of people say yes sure I'll pay five
percent more but then when they are
actually at starbucks or at a store and
they're faced with the trade-off they
will often opt for the cheaper the
cheaper option so given that dynamic
which is more pronounced in some sectors
the main driver has been basically
corporate social responsibility
commandments of very reputational II
sensitive companies nearer to the end
consumer so it's the big buyers of
products sometimes they're adopting them
because they've developed an internal
strategy that they think that it makes
sense to try and become a more corporate
socially spirometer that's a responsible
company and that gives them some
advantage in the marketplace right other
times they've been named and shamed by
NGO campaigns so a lot of the pressure
on the supply chains is targeted at
those very sensitive points in the
supply chain so a recent example of this
that was just in the media today is Lego
has currently being targeted by
Greenpeace because Lego is affiliated
with shalour it gets sources for its
plastics from shale so the strategy is
to target the very reputation ly
sensitive company to try and get
leverage on the company that's less
reputational e sensitive in that
consumer market so that dynamic is
played a critical role in creating a lot
more demand for these certification
programs so the book traces that how
that's differed in different sectors the
consequences for the uptake of different
programs so certification is is
relatively new yes yes and it's expanded
considerably when I started the project
forestry was a pretty big thing before
that organics worse of the oldest
standing type of certification before
that kosher foods is an example of this
really really early in the 20th century
kosher certification formed fair trade
is sort of another early starter but now
there's programs for biofuels for all
kinds of agric all
products textiles apparel that's growing
it yes yeah it's growing cancer who
monitors to certification fries yes I
mean how do we know people are you know
companies are doing what they really say
they're doing or that's a great question
too yeah so the the general structure of
these programs is as I sort of
highlighted one is they have a label or
logo on the end product they have a
standard then they have a governance
system that sets rules and then a
monitoring process and the monitoring
process is usually independent
certifiers so it's outside of the
company that stinks exactly and it's
even sometimes outside of the standard
setter so fair trade is not a bit of an
exception but fair trade International
has a standard setting part of its work
but then it also has a separate
organizations kind of at arm's length
called flow cert which does all the
certifications of farms that are
certified against flows operations or
its standards fair trade standards in
other sectors you see what accreditation
service that sets up so much like an
accounting firm or other certification
services they're often accredited by a
separate organization to verify that
they have the right systems in place to
capture fraud or they have the right
expertise on the teams that go out and
do the monitoring so the actual audit
process itself is usually a two-part
process one is an initial audit that
certifies whether the company meets the
standard sometimes there's correction
requests that say that you haven't met
this so you need to do this before you
get the certificate sometimes they're
ongoing requests sort of as long as you
can do some stuff to deal with these
issues over the first five years of the
certificate you can have the certificate
and so there will be an initial audit
and then a surveillance audit every year
until a reassessment occurs five years
later so that's a pretty important
mechanism for ensuring
that the companies that are actually
certified or are meeting me yeah
complain what happens have there been
any instances where people who say the
companies have sort of certification and
then the auditors find out that no in
fact they're doing something wrong and
are there any fines or what's the
penalty for non-compliance yeah so there
there have been instances where
companies have had their certifications
revoked it usually as I said before the
there's no ability really for the
organization's to find them so the
mechanism is usually that if they have a
contract with say if they're forest
products producer they have a contract
with home depot and that contract
specifies that they're supplying home
depot with certified product if they
have their certification revoked it
might mean that they lose that contract
right so there's kind of a monitor yeah
fine for her yes exactly or reputational
hit two in that they may be promoting
themselves as a responsible company to
their stakeholders and yeah right well
certification certainly seems like it is
you know a valid beneficial thing to do
are there any voices that are critical
of certification yes there's lots yeah
and what for what reasons a number of
different aspects one is the just the
big picture question of whether they're
actually doing anything terms of impacts
so a lot of these programs came about to
try and address very specific problems
so improve management of forests or
helping poor farmers get more for the
value out of their farm goods and so on
those kind of questions there have been
a lot of critical analyses the picture
is often mixed there have been certainly
places where improvements have been made
generally the so generally the programs
have been shown to make some inroads on
problems for those operations that get
certified but there is this problem that
it's voluntary
and because it's voluntary you you have
this potential that certification is
only being available for those that are
already operating reasonably close to
the standard so it gives them an
advantage and it disadvantages those
that are not close to the standard so if
you're really concerned about the big
picture problems you may not actually be
improving force management in general or
you may not be improving agricultural
practices in general you may be
improving on the margin some things on
particular forests particular operations
so that landscape level question is is a
difficult one for these programs to
resolve it's not to say that governments
have been particularly good at some of
those questions themselves but it it's
not an imperfect system and there's a
lot of research now that looks at well
how does that how do we learn from what
we've done so far and what could be
improved with the system other other
challenges are equity issues so one of
the problems with audits is they have a
built-in disadvantage for smaller
operators so audits are very expensive
so bigger companies can spread the cost
out over a larger operation so bring
down the per unit cost of an audit so if
you're a very small company you have to
face that fixed cost of the audit on for
your small operation so that also can
serve as a barrier to entry for smaller
operators so there being a lot of
efforts to try and overcome those kind
of problems with the system like group
certification or lower levels of
certification for these smaller
operators so those are really kind of
here-and-now questions that these
programs are trying to grapple with so
what do you think the future of
certification halls you think it will
continue to grow um yes I would say that
it seems like it's an instrument that
continues to have a lot of a lot of
actors are interested in seeing it
seeing how far it can go I guess the
question is on one hand there have been
some people who say it can't solve some
problems and we should sort of abandon
it and move on to other things others
are a little bit more in the middle and
say
we may not have seen its full potential
we have to sort of see how it
institutionalizes and once it's fully
institutionalized maybe we'll have a
better handle on like how far it can go
and then others are quite rah rah rah
that you know this is a this is going to
say that were less so now I think that
was earlier there was a lot of that but
there's a lot of very large companies
that have made very big commitments to
include certified sources in their in
their products so Unilever has been a
long leader in the space and they have a
very bold commitment to have all of
their palm oil supplies certified and
traceable so segmented supplies by 2020
and there at about four percent right
now so they have six years to to get to
one hundred percent so the question of
corporate commitments and how these
companies see environmental and social
performance is a component of their
business strategy think will be a really
important determinant of where these
things go in the future and also
government how government sees them and
how government interfaces them within
both in domestic context but also
internationally so let's have questions
about those barriers to trade issue that
come from these systems the inequitable
access or especially for some developing
country farmers so those are big
challenging questions and then I guess I
mean right now the EU is exploring a lot
of different ways to interact with
certification programs so though I think
there's some interesting lessons from
that space that could come for the
future and I guess the final thing I'd
say in terms of future that's sort of
interesting and potentially challenging
is so just like governments the u.s. in
order to operate has to raise revenue as
to tax right so these don't have taxing
power so they have to generate revenue
as organizations in order to sustain
themselves so how do they do that where
are the sources of revenue that are
sustainable for these organizations in
the future right now a lot of money
comes from government development
agencies or us foundations are very
heavily involved in supporting some
programs have more money from licensing
fees for their labels so that will be a
big question to how that plays out okay
very interesting thank you for being
here with us today you're welcome it was
a pleasure thank you yeah for more
information about professor alt please
visit our website at yale edu slash
mcmillan report be sure to join us again
for another episode of the macmillan
report made possible through funding
from the Whitney and Betty Macmillan
Center for International and area
studies at Yale
you